Alright, real quick, we're just going to work through these practice questions.
And we've got our reference card up here on the right, just so we can refer to what's
normal for some of these values.
And then I apologize, this video's taken me a couple takes.
That's why it's scribbled all over.
I had planned to start with a clean slate, but that didn't happen.
Alright, so let's look at this first one here.
First number is we have our CVP, which is a reflection of return to the heart or preload
to the heart.
So we'll say our CVP is up, and then our PA pressure, 38 over 18, that's high.
So we have a high ulnar artery pressure, and then our wedge pressure is 22, that's also
high.
So our wedge pressure reflects left ventricular endiastolic pressure.
So we'll just put that here, and then our wedge pressure.
So if we're looking, if we have a high value here, and here, and here, we just kind of
work through where we might have a problem.
So if we had a problem over here on the right side of the heart, yeah, we might see a high
CVP, we wouldn't necessarily see blood back up all the way over to the pulmonary system.
So that means we probably have a problem not here, but all the way around over here.
So somewhere on the left side of the heart is where we're seeing a problem, and that's
causing blood to remain here at the endiastole, back up in the lungs, and then back up through
the right side of the heart over here.
So all these options here, let's see which of these focuses on the left side of the heart
or problem with the left side of the heart.
No, no, maybe.
No, no, no.
Our most likely option here is going to be F. So if we had a mitral valve issue right
here, so if this valve is not working, we could get blood flowing from the left atrium
into left ventricle, and therefore we see pressure here at the end of diastole being
higher than we would expect.
Yeah, I did say that right.
So let's put F down for that.
You can always change your answers if you need to.
And then we'll move on to the next one here.
Okay, so this next one we have a high CVP, and that's quite a high CVP.
PA pressure is high again.
A wedge pressure is normal.
So we'll just say equal or normal.
PVR is pulmonary vascular resistance.
That's not a value.
We use a whole lot.
That's where it helps to have a reference card like this.
So normal would be under 250 and we're seeing 324.
So that's increased here.
So in this particular example, we have a normal value here.
So we probably don't have an issue here that's backing up here.
We've got something going on here in the lungs.
And then again, as before, we're seeing backup of high pressures over here into the right
side end and to our CVP, which is a measure of preload back to the heart.
So something is going on in the lungs and of our options here.
That one.
Yeah, so pulmonary arterial hypertension is our most likely guess here.
All right, so let's erase those guys.
And we'll carry on to the next one.
Okay, so we got a cardiac index of 2.2.
That's a little bit low.
So we'll draw it over here on the outflow from the heart.
So cardiac index is low.
Our CVP is 12.
So that's a little bit high.
Our wedge pressure is six.
That's normal.
And then our SVR is 1560, which is a little bit high.
Okay, so in this example, this stuff over here, let's see, cardiac index is low.
We're responding by increasing our SVR.
We don't have an issue with the outflow here because our wedge pressure is normal.
But it looks like we have something going on over here on the right side of the heart
because we're getting a high CVP.
So let's kind of look through these and see what might cause like a dysfunction over here
on the right side of the heart.
No, no, no, we've already used that one.
So here we have it, right-sided heart failure.
So if this part of the heart here, our left ventricle pushing blood out here is not working
so well, then we're going to get a back of a blood into the right atrium and then into
this area of preload return.
Now if we had other values, we could further like clarify this diagnosis.
For example, if we saw that our like pulmonary pressures were low because we're not getting
blood out of left ventricle into the pulmonary vasculature, that would be something to confirm
this diagnosis.
But we don't always have all the data points.
So based on what we have, I think our best guess here is right-sided heart failure.
All right, and then let's erase these guys and we'll carry on.
All right, our next one here, our cardiac index is 2.4, which is technically low, but it's
close enough.
So we'll say equal or low and that's a cardiac, that's a cardiac index.
And then we have a CVP and that's super low.
And then a wedge pressure, which is 4.
So this is again our left ventricular anti-stolic pressure.
Stroke volume is 45 and that's a little bit low.
So we'll put this over here as well.
Stroke volume and then our SVR is 1600, which is high.
All right, so here.
We've got decreased cardiac output, so some kind of shock state maybe or cardiac index
just low of normal.
Increase SVRs, that could be a response to decreased output.
Super low CVP, so we're definitely like down on volume somehow, whether like actually down
on volume or something makes it look like that.
And then decreased stroke volume and decreased wedge pressure.
So we're pushing a lot of stuff out of left ventricular, but we're still not getting to
our appropriate stroke volume.
So this particular situation leads me to think this is like a hypovolemic shock state.
So we just don't have enough volume going around.
A response here is our increased SVR.
So more vasoconstricting to try and accommodate, but we still have low volumes, low volumes,
low output, low output, and this is our response.
So I'm going to call this one a hypovolemic shock.
All right, so our next one here, we have a CVP of 3, so low CVP, cardiac index of 2.5.
Again, that's borderline, so we'll say that one is equal or maybe a bit low.
SVR is down.
Heart rate blood pressure is down.
And then our heart rates.
So let's get the heart rate off to the side here, and that's down.
So this one is just a classic example that you often see.
We don't necessarily need the graphic for this one, but we have a shock state based
on like a borderline, maybe low index and low, low, low values.
Normally we'd see like a compensatory increase in heart rate, but we don't see that.
So this would be your neurogenic shock state.
So that one is relatively straightforward.
All right, two more to go.
Let's see.
Okay, number six here, we have a cardiac output of 3, so that is low.
Cardiac output is down.
Our heart rate of 145, that's fast, so that's increased.
Stroke volume of 30, so that's low.
So decrease stroke volume.
SVR 2100, that's increased, sorry, there should be an up arrow.
And then a MAP of 50, which is low.
So in this situation here, let's see.
Decrease stroke volume, decrease cardiac output, decrease MAP.
So all these kind of line up and to tell us it's some kind of shock state.
Increased SVR, that could be a response to that.
And then an increased heart rate, which could also be a response.
So this is like some sort of shock state.
And the trigger here is that we have a decreased stroke volume.
So that leads us to think that it's like an issue here with the contraction of the heart
pushing blood out, which would be a cardiogenic shock state.
All right, and the last one, although we could just look at all of our options and see what's
left, we'll still work through it just like we did with the other ones.
All right, first thing is the CVP.
So our CVP is low.
Cardiac index, again, it's borderline.
SVR is low.
Blood pressure is low.
And our heart rate is 125.
So this one is relatively similar to the one before it in that like all of our measures
of like output here are down.
So some sort of shock state.
But the kicker here is that our SVR is low.
So normally, like in our example before, our cardiogenic shock state, the body compensates
for low output by increasing SVR, adding vascular tone to maintain perfusion to keep that CVP
normal or to try and keep the CVP normal.
In this situation, we don't see that.
So we have low output, increased heart rate, but our SVR stays low.
So this would be a distributive shock state.
So other options here, the only like distributive shocks we have, we have neurogenic and septic
shock.
We know because it's a test taking environment that it's not neurogenic since we already
use that option so that we could go ahead and put septic shock.
But this brings up another point just to differentiate here between these different types of shock.
So we mentioned before that the key finding for cardiogenic shock is that low output from
the left ventricle, so our decreased stroke volume.
So that's kind of how we differentiate the cardiogenic shock in our examples here.
We talked about with hypovolemic shock, how end cardiogenic shock, with both those, how
our response was an increase in SVR kind of to compensate.
And then with our distributive shock states, both septic shock and neurogenic shock, we
see a decrease in SVR.
But the difference there is that in septic shock, we do have an increase in heart rate
and in neurogenic shock, we didn't.
So that's kind of how we work through questions kind of like this using our colloidal graphic.